hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to don't escape for days in
a wasteland if you remember don't escape
or if you don't remember don't escape
here is a synopsis of what it is ah you
don't escape that there's been three
other games before this it started out
as a flash game that was trying to like
reverse the concept of an escape room
well why am i giving you a history
lesson it doesn't matter this is don't
escape for the games were amazing
they're made by script welder they're
really cool let's do this good glad we
got that out of the way
oh also their horror games if I didn't
mention that you probably noticed
because the whole intro sequence was so
spooky
that doors got some issues on it left
click to interact right-click to examine
okay a sturdy looking door now you say
sturdy looking door I say shifting in
and out of the plane of existence of
reality that we're in a kind of like
transdimensional door what about the
chimney
also script well there has like a really
unique pixelated style for their games
like just it's really cool it's locked
why am I not surprised is that what I
want though oh oh god oh god
no no wait no what was that bad
was that good what a nightmare oh okay
all right
it all felt so real yeah maybe lose the
stinging and laying eggs in my eyes my
backpack I'm not going anywhere without
it alright well got my backpack use the
backpack I can't access your inventory
notice you have a limited carry capacity
ah move my head for a moment nice so
that's where my backpack is but uh I
guess my head is gonna move to the other
side of the screen in three two one
okay good now we're good okay a sad pile
of ash it gets really cold in the desert
at night
I think this tent served me well long
enough it's too damaged to keep using it
I'll just leave it here that's not a
good idea
10 torn and damaged by the wind it won't
be of much use to me now the moon broken
into pieces you got a story behind that
or you're just gonna say that the moon's
broke into pieces
it's shattered just like all the dreams
humankind ever had oh okay mr.
depressing alright thank you for that
that's this real nice well I'll see
nuttin else
so uh I guess here we go run I don't
like the look of this cloud it seems to
be moving this way yeah you know what
you're right about that I think my
nightmare might have been more than just
a dream I still have a couple of hours
but I have to find a shelter fast oh
yeah wait hang on you saying that you
have powers of foresight Journal okay
here we go
November 21st 1996 it's been a while
since I've written anything here the
world is dead so they say so why even
bother I think the moon what's left of
it anyway he's getting bigger every day
I had a weird dream last night felt so
real I was attacked by a swarm of giant
bugs or locusts I don't know all I know
is that it was painful as hell when they
stripped the meat off my bones this
morning I saw something that looked like
a dark cloud on the horizon I know it's
not really a cloud the swarm is coming I
have to find a place to hide well the
swarm you say alright okay I love this
game already I'm so into this love the
setting love everything about em all I'm
I'm down no the wall with a small wooden
shed I mean I guess I got nothing else
to do so I guess I might as well go for
it I don't have time to walk around this
wall well good thing there's a nice
human size hole it's gotta be a faster
way to get to the other side
it's like Blue's Clues do you see a way
to get to the other side all your time
is limited to keep in mind it only
advances with certain actions you will
be warned each time before that happens
when you find a hiding place and prepare
it for the night use the clock icon to
finish the current day all right then if
it was a bit bigger I could probably get
to the other side
all right one particular wooden pole
seems to be in good condition I'll take
that oh no princess this wooden pole in
the ground seems to be stuck pulling it
out will be difficult but was
effort you should be able to get it this
action will take three minutes well I
mean yeah I guess that's not that much
time hey let's hold on here a second I
wonder what's inside alright let's let's
see what's inside the shed before we do
anything Oh a sledge hammer head a
sledge hammer head alright so if I
combine it with this pole here see I
ain't dude um here we go solid wooden
pole solid wooden sledge and let's
sledge this wall Lebowski Wow nice I can
get through to the other side of the
wall alright I guess that's what I want
to do right I'm taking everything very
slow and cautiously you guys know that
I'm not one to rush into danger so I
don't want to rush you into anything
that I'm gonna regret can get through
well I guess I could come back but I
don't know if I want to so here we go oh
that's not good it's some sort of
quicksand I'm too heavy I should get rid
of that sledgehammer okay drop an item
on the arrow button to put it on the
ground okay well I don't want to but
here we go press shift to highlight
dropped items shift oh alright well
maybe I shouldn't drop it right there
you know what I mean maybe I should drop
it over here
it's so cool uh like a persistent item
thing alright I guess I have to keep
walking vast desert lies ahead it's a
long walk though you have no other way
to traverse it this action will take 50
minutes it's 703 I mean yeah I got
nothing else to do right oh and the
journey
Oh
that's pretty cool all right
I'm down for this nice tutorial story
based tutorial it's nice not to script
welder so I kept I'm not even gonna try
I'm gonna fry that last name Wow Wow
excited about this this is a good intro
sequence give me height for it it's
pretty cool if you haven't seen the
other don't escape games or if you
haven't played them for yourself I'll
put it in the description below
like they're not story connected but the
matically you know they're all about not
escaping you know what I mean trying to
find a shelter trying to shore it up
trying to make it nice well this place
looks promising alright sure yeah is
this a [ __ ] gas station sign that
was close
Road East Road West path leads up to a
hill decent looking farmhouse well I
don't know if I'm gonna need anything
from a gas station yet so I might as
well just go for the house I suppose
it's do a decent looking farmhouse let's
go to the first place first oh no wait a
minute
I remember that window wait a minute
hang on a second it's locked I have to
break that glass if I want to get inside
alright let's go find something before I
have my trusty sledgehammer maybe I
could slew two more that thing water
sprayer that's not convenient kitchen
door it's locked
for some reason alright I guess there's
no pomp and circumstance for getting
that
alright tractor rusty piece of junk the
sad thing whoa once been out in the open
took its toll on this tractor it's
completely ruined there isn't even
anything to salvage sad thing is that
the tractor wasn't even old when the
world ended it's not as sad as you might
think it is but yeah it's sad pipes go
out far covering the fields around the
house
these pipes seem to cover a lot of area
surrounding the house with the
irrigation system probably something
about water because they just got like a
water spigot thing short pipe I'll take
that thank you
and haystack take a roll in the hay nice
nap poof hey wow a haystack I wonder if
there's a needle in it probably really
there are some seriously big holes in
this pipe alright pesticide inlet I
should find a way to
into that house before I start fiddling
with things in here you're probably
right this cargo box over here oh well I
probably can break in with this pipe but
that is convenient on the cargo box oh I
should find a way to get in the house
yeah yeah all right let's go ash your
window open I'm sure that nobody inside
will really mind right really warp this
thing not gonna do me a lot of good for
trying to keep it safe inside but you
know c'est la vie bygones are bygones
and whatnot
this place looks abandoned also familiar
staying here might be a good idea but I
only have a few hours to convert this
ruin into a fortress before my nightmare
catches up with me I should look around
and explore that road sign might be a
good start okay 753 I am I found an
abandoned house it looks like a good
place to stay I should go out explore
down the road and look for something to
fortify this place with okay this is
where my decisions can probably go awry
painting of a wooden hut all right
painting of an old-fashioned Hey Hey
that's the one that's the one the first
one I'm the first one maybe the second
ah no no photo of an old lady is taken
years ago the colors have faded a bit
but her warm smile still clearly visible
kindling box is empty the fireplace is
empty only some ashes from previous uses
still scattered all around it I also
think the chimney is clogged I don't
feel any air draft that's actually good
news at least for now yeah if it gets
cold it's bad news I'm gonna explore
that house first see if there's anything
useful in here that are leading to a
ceiling edge
nope okay I guess it's locked it's
locked and I can't find any means of
opening it all right good to know
the screen is all cracked in the case
seems partially burnt this PC won't work
won't or can't mere smear has probably
seen better-looking faces oh come on I'm
so handsome you think that I wouldn't be
looking at my own face as me we're
talking about come on and I see you
around the wasteland with the moon
hanging above like an executioner's axe
quests not that's not that's nice not
nice at all actually well so did it get
quieter nice for you around the
wasteland yeah okay now whatever you say
ma'am uh creepy
what's that keys Oh keys that's nice
okay bye milk
I think they never bought that milk well
let's check the fridge is empty after
such a long time without electricity I'm
relieved to know that yeah I've opened
the oven
I've also switched it on but nothing
happened to this no power all right well
I've closed the evidence switched it off
we'll all right then it's locked but
that's probably for the best some phone
numbers are listed on this piece of
paper but probably not important okay oh
there's some music okay I think we've
gotten everything that we need can we
use this on the door
all right I guess we should close the
door as well right that'd be smart or
close it first
all right cool it's locked but I mean
the windows still problem but it's
locked
all right good um I guess I'll go this
way down to the gas station that's
probably over here
oh no destroyed bridge time travel 15
minutes a roadblock 15 minutes okay well
are well I guess we got to go somewhere
destroyed Bridge would there even be any
point of going to the a [ __ ] I can't
make any decisions without any knowledge
small Spade that's good oh you got damn
idiots car has been wrecked beyond
repair maybe I could take its wheel off
if I had a wrench you just broke the
shovel was that my oh my own eagerness
just getting in the way I mean I can't
take these plants with me but they
probably could be useful right here by
the bridge if I had the proper tools
well I got a wooden handle that's nice
okay well whatever all right a ravine
you want me to cross the ravine this
action will take two minutes
yeah I guess right sure okay all right
two minutes yeah I'm probably gonna want
those two minutes back by the time I get
to where I need to go hello hello
anybody there is a lighter here that
could be useful hurry nothing left that
could be useful crowbar uh do you want
to free the crowbar using brute force
the crowbar seems to be really stuck in
there it might not be easy to get out
with your bare hands I guess I'm good
take the hunting rifle though gas
canister yes please it's empty well the
container might be useful a bag of
charcoal be careful what you pick up you
won't need every single item you find I
mean what about the charcoal that seems
useful a newspaper from long ago sits in
the magazine stand lunar explosion the
world is still in shock after
yesterday's explosion that has left our
moon with huge cracks visible to the
naked eye from Earth scientists say that
while it may look dangerous there is no
need for concern the cracks are surface
level only and the explosions will have
no serious consequences I'm guessing
that's not what happened the cause of
the event is still unknown many point to
one of the world's largest tech
corporations sidereal plexes that was
rumored to launch a mining operation on
the moon
earlier this year the spokesman from the
company was denied these claims yes we
are preparing for to dig for helium-3
this autumn but I assure you we haven't
even started now of course the whole
operation is going to be halted until
further notice yes other experts believe
the explosion was caught by an
undetected meteor that crashed into the
moon whatever the case might be the
government of the world urged people to
remain calm well I guess that didn't go
so well
so depop little bars all useful it's too
heavy I have to put something down first
um well probably one metal bar is gonna
be good a bag of charcoal is 10
kilograms do I need charcoal probably
not you know since that was the item
that was little everything maybe maybe I
don't need charcoal well I mean I don't
know I don't need charcoal huh all right
um well I don't know if I need two metal
bars but I like the idea of having two
metal bars I really like that idea no I
don't like having to make these
decisions these decisions aren't as fun
small rock why am I looking at the
window right on here we go um I have a
hunting rifle and some bullets not a
perfect weapon against the bastards but
it will probably help what else can I do
to prepare well I can fix that window
that's the first thing that I could do
the plastic would help with that right
probably a rock guys it's a rock I
didn't waste one kilogram oh I can't
even pick up a rock huh all right well
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
just I guess I guess what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna drop this I'm gonna drop
this for now but drop those I'm gonna go
get the rock because I like the rocks
the rocks gonna be my friend everybody
say hi to shiny rock no teensy Rock pony
Tata piddly pebble Paul piddly pebble
Peterson
Peter Peter the piddly pebble it'll
build Peter Peter Peter
I don't remember I have no idea fuel
valves where we get there is a valve
from which the fuel should flow but how
do I open it good question how do I open
shoot it I shouldn't do that
but I want to and wait let me see save
game here we go let me save real quick
before I use bad idea are you sure about
that or are you sure about that I can't
see how that would work well you're
stupid then you lack imagination all
right then fine
light it on fire not really
all right whatever screw you you nerd so
I think that's probably everything in
here besides the crowbar I mean it's
only five minutes so yeah that's a good
idea right it was a good idea probably I
could take another plastic wrap with me
I'd be good and then I'm pretty full up
I think this is good enough right I
don't know what I need so I guess I just
got a guess and work back just just
knowing what I was doing there was a
window that's broken so logically Oh God
carrying more stuff affects my climbing
speeds Oh God
alright whatever then let's go back home
first drop off some stuff see if we can
like I don't know let's climb in that
window uh let's see if we can like
plastic the window up it's just hanging
there I still should do something to
attach it to the wall around the window
well I could burn it
I'm a Stephenie R remember your
inventory is limited you can put item
here for later use you can also just
drop them on the ground they will not
disappear alright we're gonna put the
metal the plastic we're gonna keep the
crowbar we're gonna put the fuel
canister in there keep the rock with us
it's a small rock small rock Smith No
puny rock Percival that's what he is
that's his name puny rock Percival no
he's she's strong
many rock marshall battle that's it no
meanie rock max yeah narc Marshall mini
Rock Marshall yeah okay mini rock
Marshall okay alright mini rock Marshall
put a face on that rock that rock is the
new mascot get our tiny box cam you've
done yeah we got this we got this
yay I don't know what I'm gonna need so
I might as well keep the light stuff uh
crowbar probably useful
all right mini rock Marshall all right
let's get out of can we just burst
through this cool so I put the heavy
stuff away wait no I did not
let's do that okay that's good now I
should be able to get more stuff and we
don't have to take this goddamn plastic
wrap with us okay let's see what else we
need oh god those corpses are partially
eaten the swarm got them it looks like
these men put up a fight and killed a
bunch of the insects but they didn't
stand a chance in the open
yeah that's obviously true something
shines between the pieces of the torn
bag that he was carrying well as well
grab it there was a strange remote
controller and the corpses bag alright
good great I have to take a closer look
to check out this vehicle well I don't
want to do that yet Oh a wrench let's
hope this will be more useful to me than
a most of them there is a small leaflet
tucked between the folds of the ripped
clothes attention team as of this week
we've been hired by the locals to help
deal with a new kind of locust
terrorizing the area perhaps we'll
finally use our sonic repellent device
it fans off different kinds of insects
you just have to installed on the ground
but before you can start counting on it
you have to know exactly what type of
insects you're dealing with and set the
right frequency with a remote controller
I know this job sounds exhausting and a
bit dangerous but at this point we need
the food and fuel the locals are paying
with alright ok let's just search this
car let's do it get plenty of time the
car is busted so it's not going anywhere
one part that seems to be fine is the
ignition coil but getting it out won't
be easy well I don't know that I need it
yet I guess I could remove the ignition
coil but I wouldn't even just will
wrench for that oh well I guess I got
one well let's see
45 yes do it why not I don't know what I
don't know why I need it but um I got it
wasting my time right bye
see you guys thanks for the supplies hey
there truck the back door is locked
how about a crew burr there we go I knew
I got a good reason for getting that
yeah this don't look so good
what if we got kin of pesticide oh
that's good it's locked
well is it locked for me nah nah yeah
yeah there we go
whoa what the hell is that
sonic repellent device drop this item to
set it up okay yeah all right why am i
carrying that no no oh there's a note
hang on oh oh that's handy oh well let's
take a look at that that's why I picked
this up okay all right so it's got
stubby legs these things go back it's
got two long pincers I don't know oh I
kept the note okay here we go
all right so stubby legs like this legs
go back and forward
stubby pincers and fat legs I think it's
4:20
I think 4:20 is the answer yeah yeah
4:20 yeah 4:20 yeah okay I think that's
everything in here oh god I didn't know
that guy
well I got what I needed I think anyway
so yeah okay goodbye I guess let me go
drop some stuff off first I think I got
what I need to go get the fuel now I've
got an adjustable wrench which I know
could help out so let me grab the fuel
can let me drop off the pesticide I
might need the duct tape ignition coil
I'm gonna keep here Sonic appellant here
remote controller keep the Kroeber that
insect and this note can stay here and
I'm gonna keep this stuff just in case
and I can grab more if I know if I'm
careful about what I bring I could grab
more stuff I'm guessing I don't need the
rifle I want to keep this rock on me
hammer with a broken handle maybe I
could do maybe I could fix this that
won't work
I need a new handle for this hammer oh
well oh well that was easy but do I need
this hammer with me is the question yeah
maybe yeah why not okay you know what
why not
alright let's go for it let's do this
now let's use the wrench on this there's
a valve from which the fuel should open
but
I open it with the wrench there you go
whoa whoa wait wait what oh yeah wait no
yeah I by man idiot I'm an idiot yep
there we go that's I'm real dumb I'm
real dumb real dumb oh yeah perfect
perfect okay cool
how much dude that way ten ten my left
no I shouldn't have brought all this
other car I really shouldn't have
brought this other crap um okay well the
only thing that I can bring is the metal
bars so I'm gonna bring the metal bars I
meant to bring more plastic but you know
I always come back bad you know it's
fine actually wait let me let me save go
quick maybe I should've saved before I'm
gonna make so many mistakes I already
know this I'm gonna stop by this place
real quick cuz I want to go to the car
right here real quick it was something
else that I need I have a wrench so
let's take the wheel off I don't know if
we'll be able to carry it yes her from
almost falling off the cliff once all
went well I got the wheel Oh perfect all
right good then we're good we just got
to go back and then we got to make sure
that we don't die here so he's kind of
uh we got a buttload of supplies I don't
know what else to get I don't have nails
oh I have duct tape okay so let's get
the wheel there let's leave the metal
grade there as well we're gonna take
this plastic and we're gonna try to fix
it with the duct tape which makes sense
but that there duct tape wait no I need
nails to do this where am I gonna get
nails hang on let me think about this
I could recycle from some of the nails
that hold this together but I need a
tool for that hammer yes I need nails
nails are gonna be better than duct tape
and duct tape is more uses than just
getting things to walls yeah we're
getting on to something yeah all right
this car seems to be in bad shape
without taking a moment to inspect you
can't be sure what it needs to be done
apart from finding a spare wheel of
course checking on it will take some
time yeah let's do that
well the car could be started I guess
but it doesn't look very good obviously
a wheel is missing the ignition coil is
busted it has no fuel well all right
wait do you want to pour some fuel yeah
I fueled the car I have
all those things I have all those things
I have all those things I have the wheel
it's flat probably but I have the wheel
and I have the ignition coil maybe that
would cut down my travel time do you
want to do this 15 minutes yeah I do
mission coil 15 minutes yeah I've
installed a part will the karst Hey look
at that I don't know if it'll go there
because the truck might not be able to
jump that but I should go back get more
fuel then yeah can't be reached by car
there's a broken bridge in the way
that's right oh that makes sense
but it can help me get I can get the
rest of the supplies and then I could go
grab more gas on foot
okay wait before I do that yeah cancel
this cancel this all right before I do
that before I do that let me grab all of
the supplies that I had out of the chest
the kind of tools and [ __ ] actually Han
let me just go ahead and put this up
here a hammer nails to attach the
plastic wrap to the window frame the
section will take 20 minutes I'll hold
off on it then okay I'll I'll do that
later then cuz I don't I don't know if
I'm gonna need these nails for any
particular reason later cuz I might need
them to fix the bridge because maybe the
wood I nail it down bada-bing bada-boom
I'm not gonna leave anything behind
all right let's do this I'm gonna take
the truck cuz why not it saves time I've
spent the time fixing it up so I might
as well spend the time going here bro
okay so now what I'm going to do can't
take that probably use proper tools I
have tools with that work use hammer on
planks hammer this will require one
handful of nails but it will allow you
to travel to the ravine without any
delays however you'll still have to stop
your vehicle here if you have one it's
ninety minutes that's a lot of time boy
I'm planning for the future here I'm
planning for the future and if I'm
planning for the future then this seems
like a good idea
nice okay then I go to the gas station I
get more gas so that I have
extra if I want more gas and then I'm
set up for success down the road I'm
guessing that this thing has so much gas
in it that it's never gonna run out
hopefully anyway all right what do I got
I can carry another metal grate and
eventually the bag of charcoal but you
know they said I didn't need that so
whatever cool cool cool tight tight
tight let me see if I'm let me see I can
put this in the generator and see what
that does
fueled up the generator now I just have
to start it okay house it choke didn't
start come on start already yay it's
running shocking that's good right oh we
have power well la dee de la Vida holy
[ __ ] we're really turning this place
into a home let me try to use the
Kroeber on the patch I wouldn't be able
to pry it open anyway I should just
leave it for now okay whatever you say
man you big baby
okay so that windows fine this window is
fine so in order to shore up this thing
what I'm going to do is I need to get
more nails I need more I need more nails
I need more nails all right so I got the
I'm gonna actually do the window this
time right get that up do you always app
last hammer and the nails attach the
plastic wrap to the window would it be
better okay would it be better I'm
curious like cuz my instinct tells me if
insects are gonna be getting there the
plastic would keep it out because of
mosquitoes but what if I double do it
what if I do it double style cuz maybe I
maybe I only have so many nails it's
just hanging there what if I do double
there's something else in the window I
should remove it first so I can't do
double my only question is that I don't
know if these bugs are gonna like slip
through the bars cuz they might they
might slip through so I guess until I
know I'm gonna I'm gonna wait I want to
I want to go get more gas cuz I can
because I have that time for it I think
anyway
might as well go get more gas and get
that last piece of plastic before the
night do planks oh cool put these in the
truck storage okay I'm gonna head to the
bridge real quick I'm gonna hop out I'm
gonna go west
I'm gonna grab even more fuel because
I've got the time I'm gonna run through
your real quick and just double-check
cash well you never know maybe it's
gonna be worth something again someday
yeah probably not but okay I like your
optimism the plastic wrap if I have the
time I want to make sure that I have
fuel I don't know if I'm gonna need this
much fuel but having having a full
canister fuel cannot be a bad thing and
then I got just enough for the charcoal
ah well fancy that and I think I've
cleared this entire place out nice I
don't know if the charcoal is worth
anything
honestly I don't all right so there are
four hours and 15 minutes left what I
have to do is I have to shore up this
house to make sure that the bugs can't
get in and eat my flesh I am unsure
about the strength of a plastic sheet on
the window but at the same time not the
worst idea because maybe they would slip
right through the holes of the metal
grate so I just got to make a call also
we've got this sonic device but I'm not
a hundred percent sure about how to
utilize it if it needs to be like in the
house I don't know if that helps does
that help
I have no idea I'm gonna take more stuff
from the greenhouse it's because I want
to get all of it because I just
remembered something in my dream the one
where I died those little bastards just
blasted right the heck through my entire
day they didn't care that there was
glass there so I need something at the
end of the day I need something stronger
than glass I think and is the best I
just for if if okay it's the hip it's
the heavier thing I'm thinking that it's
the better idea either
I mean I've also got planks of wood I I
guess I could the planks are too rotten
and fragile to be of any use here yeah
yeah it makes a make sense yeah it makes
sense could put them in the fireplace I
guess or save them for the fireplace but
I'm thinking okay they give three
plastic sheets and then three metal bars
I'm thinking that the metal bars are
I've got three windows in the place I
think that
that's a wait there's a window hang on a
second okay no you can't do that okay
I'm thinking that the metal bars there's
three broken planks there's three of
these things I feel like it's minecraft
again I've got three of those let make
him in like a t-shape I can make a shirt
nice Armour get that I'm gonna carry
this on me now
ah indecision is crippling me maybe I
could put this in the kindling box I
don't have any fuel in the kindling box
I don't plan on letting a fire for now
all right fair okay all right I know
I've saved my game like 15 times now but
I'm just gonna I'm gonna commit I'm
gonna commit to this yeah I'm gonna do
this we're gonna I'm gonna go for it
we're gonna go we're good on for it man
I guess I could try the pesticide thing
but I don't know what the pesticide
would be for why would I need that
I mean pesticide yeah the bugs but I
don't know if that's actually gonna help
is it gonna help would it help I don't
know man there's no crops why would I
bother with that let's save it until we
know we need it and see that okay all
right I'm done pussyfooting around with
indecision it's time to get good or get
gone I'm gonna get if we're gonna get
good I'm gonna go for the metal cuz I'm
metal no not not that um I'm gonna go
for the metal because I'm metal as hell
you want to hammer the nails and test
the metal bars yes I do I want yeah
exactly
okay I installed iron bars in one of the
windows is there anything else I can do
not a thing not a damn thing was put put
get some more get some more metal oh
yeah here we go baby oh yeah now this is
what I have been talking about yeah it's
what I've been talking about this is
what I've always talked about everyone
knows this or here we go
guys this is gonna be this is the real
deal this is what this one genius-level
gameplay like this is what you really
signed up for right this is the kind of
top-tier 200 IQ thinking that you guys
really appreciate so those aren't bars
they're not going No
we're yeah they're not going nowhere oh
we're getting cozy up in here oh yeah
and you know what else I'm gonna do you
know what else I'm gonna do I'm gonna
set of the sonic device right here in
the living room ain't never gonna get in
here no no no
no way no how and I think it's 420 420
I'm pretty sure I'm almost positive I am
a hundred percent positive because this
foreleg sticky-outy long pincers Ford
legs sticky-outy long pincers that's
what that is
right yeah that's what that is okay cool
so I think we're kind of good right
there's some time left in the day but I
don't know what else we could get they
move scavenged everything we possibly
good I think we're good yeah let's let's
save her up another I'm out of slay save
slots already
let's save Rob let's do this do this are
the doors locked make sure let me make
sure is it locked
okay it's locked it's locked okay those
are locked time to time to go here we go
pick one item for unit or that you would
like to equip during the night or cancel
if you don't want to finish the day just
yet oh god how about a wrench because I
don't think a gun would be good to shoot
bugs do a wrench yeah I'll do the wrench
yeah it didn't really help the other
guys but you know probably better than a
gun yes do this an evening sky darkened
is the black cloud of swarm arrived you
found a hiding place in an abandoned
farmhouse you deployed the sonic
repellent device to fend off some of the
insects it was placed inside the hideout
the walls probably weakened oh [ __ ]
the device seemed to be set to the
correct frequency fending off 25 insects
oh god damn it the front doors closed
keeping away all the 35 locusts that
would have entered through it the back
door was closed keeping away all the 35
locusts yeah
the window on the ground floor was
reinforced with metal bars the bars were
nailed to the frame out of 35 insects
that tried to enter the house through
that window 9 were stopped oh we know
how the upper floor was reinforced out
of 35 10 were stopped
oh the bathroom was reinforced the bars
were nailed to frame
oh they got in oh a wrench was your last
line of defense you managed to knock
down 20
oh god no oh oh oh no the death was
painful and slow not merciful at all
that was a painful death just like in
your nightmare maybe there was something
that could have been done to prevent it
oh right I'm just gonna pick this up and
oh well [ __ ] right so that was very
death first of all we're gonna put this
bad boy right here drop that bad boy
right there I'll put the sonic Norris it
should scare something so I configured
it right yeah well yeah 420 okay all
right no weak signals here all right so
I'm gonna also do like the insecticide
stuff cuz I'm thinking now that maybe
maybe I shouldn't wait maybe maybe
waiting isn't the best option maybe
waiting is not exactly what uh what we
were hoping for okay let's do let's do
some of this okay first off we're gonna
fix this bad boy we're gonna fix it fix
it right up right we're gonna fix it Wow
we're gonna fix it right up yeah fix
that bad boy okay that's fixed good put
enough duct tape make it last till the
end of time well until Thursday that is
why what happens Thursday what are you
saying what happens to stick all right
so then we're gonna put some insecticide
in there then we're gonna switch this
over because we don't eat house power
why would we need house bar water pump
and water pump and irrigation control
system okay overnight mist spray
irrigation this should cause the night
sky to be soaked with a dense mist oh
yeah oh whoops oh oh so it's a puzzle
well good thing I'm so good at these
done all right I scheduled the water
sprinkles to put us a wall of mist with
some extra pesticide solution can I
improve my chances somehow okay what if
I do I have to use all of it though I
think that using all of it might be
unwise we're gonna close this lock that
up close this we're gonna lock that up
good duct tape doing no ooh wait no I
already got
they're already affixed already there
it's already perfect
all right cool let's save her up I think
now we're gonna have a much better
solution to this alright ready who's
ready I'm ready let's do this let's take
the ranch dad perfect okay here we go
found a hiding place in a house
automated sprinkler system kicked in as
the swarm was getting the air despite
being old and faulty the sprinklers
worked perfectly yes fully covering the
air above the fields with a dense mist
as a result 32 insects will stop at the
sprinkler yes it was a strong pesticide
mixed with the water making this wall of
water more dangerous to the incoming
swarm killed 24 insects us deployed the
sonic repellent to fend off some of the
insects this place area hideout so the
signal was strong the device seemed to
be set to the correct frequency fending
off 50 yes front door was closed keeping
away 19 backdoor 19 window guards were
nailed to the frame 9 were stopped 10
were stopped 10 were stopped 27 that's a
lot Oh Oh God 7 got through their bites
were painful as they're tiny sharp teeth
shredded your skin but it wasn't enough
to kill you somehow you managed to tear
that each stagger off your body and
killing in chaotic dirty fight wait no
what no wait no stop I don't want to
know this wait no stop I can do better I
know I can do better I can do better
guys stay with me I can do better
I can do better doesn't sound like words
anymore I can do better I can do better
I can do better I can do better I can do
better you got to believe me I can do
better
ok let me do I want to try something
else no not that I want to try this and
yeah I got this hang on guys I could do
better everybody hold on I'll be right
back ok so now I switch it out to
plastic wrap I don't know if that's
gonna be better than the middle but I
also use double the pesticide so
hopefully hopefully it'll be fun and I'm
gonna use the gun not that I think it's
gonna be any good but I'm gonna use the
gun ok so we're all good
use the gun and let's see what happens
okay fine hiding place
32 we're sought by the sprinklers 48
killed by the pesticide that's pretty
good
see 50 insects gone 14 14 out of 14
incest to try to enter the through that
window 14 were stopped yes
plastic is the correct answer oh oh oh
hell yeah Oh plastic was right ah oh oh
that's what I like to see us what I like
to see that's all them you fend it off
all the insects before they even entered
the house you went to bed early and had
a well-deserved rest allowing you to
regain some strength plus 5 kilogram
permanent Gary whip
Oh using that you okay cool great got
that now now I can know what the hell is
happening here Wow a helo chopper
oh god damn you to hell
oh it's money it's my dream uh-oh Wow
this ain't too good a little ooh dude
it's locked the window oh oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh what the hell I'm
burning on Oh God okay well I'm dead now
ah that's no good okay well that's a
problem
what was that the attic yeah okay all
right well a destroyed barricade
destroyed just destroyed [ __ ]
what do you mean destroyed did they
actually destroy it all oh [ __ ] they did
I didn't know that that was temporary
well [ __ ] well anyway so that is all the
time after this episode of don't escape
for but I want to play through this
whole thing and there's four days four
days in the wasteland so one a day in
episode and I will look forward to
playing through this we got to go up
into the attic next but thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down the comments
below and as always see you in the next
video
[Music]